[Music]
i've been
working on machine learning for many
years and last five years i've been
focusing on uh deep learning for
conversational ai interface
so before servicenow i started a
conversational ai company passage ai
and uh so this is some of the lessons
i learned building conversational ai
interfaces in last five years
so let me start talking about what i
mean by conversational ai
interfaces so we see now more than 300
million
smart speakers from alexa devices to
google home and they are growing very
rapidly and in fact it's predicted to
overtake tablet
number of tablets this year
and also we have billions of users on
messaging platforms like facebook
messenger
whatsapp microsoft teams slack and so on
and all these uh messaging platforms
have been opened up for developing uh
virtual agents uh
messaging bots and
[Music]
any business can create a conversational
interface on these messaging platforms
and we also see more and more devices
with conversational interfaces
like tv remotes variables and so on
and uh it's great to see
these conversational interfaces on these
new devices and you don't need to
learn new interface for each device and
you can just converse
with these devices and
i see conversational interfaces are
future of computing interfaces where
every computer is equipped with a
conversational interface it's already
happening
from microsoft cortana siri google
assistant
alexa and so on
uh just a few years back uh uh this is a
uh screenshot from movie her conversing
with
device seems like a science fiction but
it's a reality now at the same time when
we see enterprise
side eighty percent of businesses want a
an automated conversational interface uh
uh very soon so that they can
automate various parts of customer
service
and be available to their customer 24 7
rather than only during business hours
at the same time more and more customers
are getting used to bots or virtual
agents
and they would prefer talking to bots to
resolve their
issue rather than waiting online or
in the weekend not able to reach out to
customer service
so what does it take to build a
conversational interface
so there are three components to build a
the first one is the ability to define
workflows and interactions
and i'll go a little bit more in detail
of what i mean
by ability to define interaction and
workflows
the second part is natural language
understanding
processing and have a conversational ai
capability
and the third is ability to converse
with users in their medium of choosing
whether it is a voice medium or
messaging medium and adopt
for voice or messaging mediums
with native capabilities of that medium
so what are the building blocks for
conversational interface experience
the first one is uh ability to define
interaction uh it could be a mind map of
user interaction and ability to handle
errors and disambiguate
the second building block is having
a way to define workflow using tools
like intents
api calls decision tree knowledge basis
and the third is ability to train
conversational ai
to by providing a definition of intent
utterances
and what kind of responses are expected
so uh some lessons uh developing
conversational interaction design
make it personable instead of let's say
just saying hi
how can i help say happy friday pete
uh uh what can i do for you uh
may be available all the time uh not
just
navigational because in the middle of
your navigational
workflow a user may ask to do something
and your virtual agent should be able to
respond back
ask for clarification and disambiguate
in cases of ambiguity or many choices to
narrow down
choices and never end conversation
some point and the ability to handle
errors
and not supported features gracefully
here are some of the building blocks to
build the workflows
intent is one abstraction to define a
use case
that can capture meaning behind messages
and curate responses
have ability to define action
fulfillment
and workflows uh by making api calls
or executing a particular workflow
so example of workflow could be let's
say
for uh customer service for e-commerce
it could be order tracking
uh workflow or in an enterprise
environment let's say somebody wants to
reset their password
uh have the ability to get appropriate
variables and parameters
and execute a workflow to do certain
tasks
decision tree so troubleshooting like
use cases you want to walk down
a certain path of troubleshooting and
have a decision based on what user has
responded
so far and finally knowledge base for
question answering lot of information is
restored
in knowledge bases documents and be able
to extract
right answer for a given question
so let me switch here and talk about
how advances in deep learning
technologies are
making conversational ai reality
so first step in making a virtual agent
intelligent is to understand what users
are saying
this involves natural language
understanding
such as extracting right pieces of
information
entities location names etc and
also understand meaning behind the
messages
through abstraction of intents uh
i gave couple of examples let's say
order tracking
in case of e-commerce or
reset password intent in case of
enterprise those could be examples of
various intents
finally need to understand what actions
you
users want to take and do appropriate
action like trying to get more
information from users
uh to execute certain action so for
example
in case of order tracking intent you
need
order id from the users and
also have an ability to uh verify
the you the user you are talking to
similarly for reset password you may
want to authenticate users and
get some information back to execute
that action further also
ability to respond back to users in
natural language is important
and all this is feasible using
some of the latest deep learning
technologies
so here is two minute introduction to
deep learning
in traditional machine learning someone
has to design
features and engineer those features
and machine learning model optimize
weights
or come up with a combination function
that combines those features
to predict uh the outcome
on the other hand deep learning stance
which normally stands for deep neural
network
you have layers of neural network deep
neural networks
and they are good in understanding
uh various levels of representations
from the data
so you feed the training data and the
outcome
and various layers understand various
features
and levels of representation for a given
input for example
in k this case uh this is uh
uh let's say a convolution deep neural
network to identify
face human face versus cat face
uh you have uh convolution uh
layers max pooling layers combination of
that
and then dense layer and softmax to be
able to
understand various uh feature
representation
uh whether it's uh like
lines on the face and so on
and finally predict whether it is a
human face or cat face
more recently deep learning has been
very successfully applied for various
natural language processing tasks
whether it is language translation
question answering
speech recognition and so on and
i'll briefly describe two important
technique one
is having a pre-trained language models
for embedding
uh uh and second is adaptation
and fine tuning uh so examples of
pre-trained language models for
embeddings include vertovac
uh that revolutionized the nlp world in
uh 2012 2013 globe from stanford
almo from alana institute ulm fit
uh gpt from open ai and bird from google
so these are some of the
examples of free trained language models
uh
that are making lot of impact in
natural language processing world and uh
uh i'll go into some of the techniques
for adaptation and fine-tuning
recurrent neural networks and example of
that is long short-term memory network
as well as transformer network with
attention
uh models are used for adaptation and
fine tuning for a particular
uh nlp task
so so let me briefly describe what i
mean by pre-trained
language models for embedding so
to just to give an uh an example is
word to web that came out in 2012 from
google
and that has completely changed the
world of
nlp in last eight years and what do i
cuber embed words in a continuous vector
space
so that semantically similar words are
mapped to nearby points
this enables very powerful analogy
operations so you can do things like
king minus man plus woman
is a vector representation of these
words
uh the vector you get is very the very
close
to the word queen uh vector and
you can deduce such analogy uh from word
to work
before virtual came out a natural
language processing
text processing used to suffer from
curse of dimensionality
so so in bhagavad
model you normally have a dictionary of
words
and counts in text you use that to
represent each word
it's a an easy feature generation
technique for text processing
but it has lot of limitations for
example it's very hard to capture
order of words and it suffers from curse
of dimensionality
uh because uh like uh uh
yeah since let's say you have to use 50
000 dictionary for
english even a similar words
may map in far away data points and
very hard to capture similarity between
words
so word embedding in some sense
addresses
this curse of dimensionality and reduce
uh
eliminates those uh uh limitations uh
from bag of word it's uh uh and even
with more recent techniques like bert
elmo
you are able to even contextually
capture the meaning of word and
the as well as map the words in a higher
dimensional space
typically 200 to 500
and learn representation of words in
this higher dimensional
space so that semantically similar words
are mapped to similar space
in vector space and this enables very
powerful
analogy operations for example distance
between
uh word vector for france and what
vector of paris
is similar to distance between word
vector of italy and
word vector of rom and
this helps in a lot of text processing
task
let's say for example uh you want to
find out
let's say capital of uh uh each
country uh that kind of task if you want
to train
with even a small training data you can
uh do a really good job for such tasks
and how do you train such a word
embedding
uh one way uh simple way for example to
train
uh word embedding could be a train two
layer neural network to
learn word representation by predicting
next word from a phrase and output of
first layer
in your two layer neural network you
could use
as a word embedding in fact gpt
123 use next word prediction as
uh their training task for pre
pre-trained uh language models
uh so there's a lot of recent
advancement
in embedding so some of the examples
are a couple of years back elmo came out
from allen institute of ai
that uses bi-directional lstm network
uh trained on a particular nlp task for
example text classification
to generate uh a contextual word
embedding
so so uh because of lstm layers so let's
say the broadway play premiered
yesterday
the play uh would capture uh
embedding would be closer to let's say
theatrical play
versus let's say a sentence like i want
to play soccer
it will be a different word vector
because of
the contextual representation and you
learn this
contextual representation by combining
the final output the middle layer and
the initial layer output
uh but is another one that came out late
uh
2018 and there has been a lot of
variants of
birth uh that are very successful
and that uses uh something called
transformer
network with self-attention layer to
capture
importance of words and in this uh
these are somewhat faster because each
word can be processed
in parallel and you can get contextual
word embedding using models like bird
also uh there's sentence embedding not
that are very useful in many different
contexts especially in search and
similarity
where you encode the whole sentence
contextually
and google's universal sentence encoding
is one of such example that also uses
transformer network
for pre-training
uh so let me talk about the
other component of
natural language processing tasks for
adoptation and fine tuning for a
particular task
and sequence learning models and
transformer network are two examples of
such adaptation and fine tuning where
deep neural network has been very
successfully applied
so let let me talk about the first one
which is using sequence learning model
uh
that sequence to sequence model that
came out about four years back from
google and it has been successfully
applied
for gmail smart reply that uses
a form of recurrent neural network
called a long short-term memory network
so in neural recurrent neural network
output of one module go into model of
the same type
and this is good for capturing sequences
like sequence of words sequence of
characters
uh sequence of his spoken words and
things like that
and long short term memory network is
one example of recurrent neural network
which has one long running cell state
and output is a combination of
the long running cell state the previous
cell output
and the current input and this kind of
combination
uh helps in capturing the dependency
between uh words
in a test text sequence or characters in
the text sequence
and uh having the ability to forget
uh long uh dependency uh
uh helps in addressing some of the
uh limitations of earlier recurrent
neural network
uh like exploding gradient uh
uh so so another form of deep neural
network that has
gained a lot of attention in last three
years our
transformer network these are
basically layers of attention layers
and feed forward normalization and
there's an encoder layer and decoder
layer
and uh multiple
layers of transformers can be put
together
for example but uses 24 layers of
transformer
encoder are trained on a
next sentence prediction task with
masking
to retrain a language model
gpt 3 that uh that is gaining a lot of
attention recently that uses
96 layers of transformer decoder
are trained on next word prediction task
and these pre-trained language models
come out of the box trained using a lot
of data
for example gpt 3
uses like terabytes
of data and it has
175 billion parameters uh
according to some estimates that it took
12 million dollars to just uh pre-train
the gp3
uh model so so these are uh trained on
large
amount of data very large model but they
come out of the box
with ability to do a lot of natural
language processing tasks
and on top of that you can fine-tune
them
and to adopt to your particular uh
nlp task so
so some of the nlp tasks that
makes conversational ai reality includes
identifying intents extracting
named entities filling up slots for i
mentioned order tracking example where
order id
is important uh sentiment analysis
uh knowledge base uh semantic search
machine reading comprehension for
question answering
all these def different components of
conversational
ai is possible using some of these
latest deep learning technologies
like pre-trained language models and
adaptation and fine tuning
so how do you train these
various models you need you need to
provide ways of saying the same thing in
different ways
uh provide various label data for
different tasks from intent
identification to entity extraction to
question answering and avoid enough
training data to
provide enough training data to avoid
overfitting
and uh you can divide the training phase
where there's more powerful machines
like gpus
and a lot of data a lot of time can be
taken to train your models
and use those models uh
inside a service to do various uh
prediction tasks that can scale up with
your uh
service load so that's a kind of summary
of
what i talked today i talked about
why conversational interfaces are so
important and future of computing
interfaces
uh what are the building blocks for
building conversational interface
experience uh from the ability to define
various
workflows and the ability to train
natural language processing models and
ability to have uh your interactions
uh uh uh utilizing the native
uh messaging on conversational
environment
and finally i talked about
how some of the latest advances in deep
neural networks
uh from pre-trained language models like
bird gpt3 to some of
the fine-tuning adaptation layers like
long short-term memory network or
transformer network
are making conversational ai a reality
[Music]